SPEAKER: "Critter
Junction" has their eye
on reducing cold start latency.
And that's going to take
a bit of detective work.
Stay tuned to see how
they profile start up
times to speed things up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
"Critter Junction's"
been seeing longer than
wanted startup times through
their Compute Engine instances
even though they set everything
according to our auto scaling
recommendations.
They know they were running
into some logic on their game
servers on Compute
Engine like taking
user inputs to spawn them
into a new Critter's island.
But after profiling
their startup times,
they were seeing more
than 380 second cold start
times while the response
latency for a request
was in the 300
millisecond range.
They also did a performance test
to see how long Compute Engine
was taking to create those
instances versus how much time
their code was taking to run.
This showed request,
provision, and boot time
straight from the Cloud Shell.
Request is the time
between asking for a VM
and getting a response back
from the Create Instance API
acknowledging that
you've asked for it.
You can profile this
by timing how long
it takes Google Cloud to respond
to the insert instance rest
command.
Provision is the time
that Compute Engine
takes to find space for
the VM on its architecture.
Use the get instance
API on a regular basis
and wait for the
status flag to change
from provisioning to running.
And boot time is when startup
scripts and other custom code
executes up to the point when
the instance is available.
Just repeatedly pull
a health check that
is served by the same
runtime as your app,
then time the change
between receiving 500, 400,
and 200 status codes.
After doing these,
"Critter Junction"
noticed the majority
of instant startup time
usually happened
during the boot phase
when the instance
execute startup scripts.
This is not uncommon, so
you should profile your boot
scripts to see which phases
are creating performance
bottlenecks.
To get a sense of what
stages of your script
are taking the most
boot time, one trick
is to wrap each section
of your startup script
with the seconds
command, then append
the time elapsed for
each stage to a file,
and set up a new end point to
serve that file when requested.
This let "Critter
Junction" dig even deeper
to pull the end point
and get data back
without too much heavy
lifting or any modification
to their service.
And there it is.
The performance
bottleneck seemed
to be public images,
preconfigured combinations
of the OS, and boot loaders.
These images are great when
you want to get up and running.
But as you start building
production level systems,
the large portion
of boot up time
is no longer booting
the OS but the user
executed startup sequence that
grabs packages and binaries
and initializes them.
"Critter Junction" was
able to address this
by creating custom images for
their instances, which you can
do from source disks, images,
snapshots, or images stored
in Cloud storage.
Then use those images
to create VM instances.
When the target
instance is booted,
the image information is
copied right to the hard drive.
This is great when you've
created and modified
a root persistent disk
to a certain state
and want to save that state
to reuse it with new instances
and when your setup includes
installing and compiling
big libraries or
pieces of software.
When you're trying to scale to
millions of requests per second
being serviced by
thousands of instances,
a small change in boot time can
make a really big difference
in costs, response time,
and most importantly,
the perception of
performance by your users.
Stay tuned for what's next
for "Critter Junction."
And remember, always
be architecting.